I will always be Australia and honestly  I can't wait to get back to all of my  animals and then to just go and lay  under the trees with my snake and my  rhinos it'll be so nice from the  ballroom to the zoo bindi Irwin returned  to her native land on Monday and got  right back to business swapping her  glittery costumes for traditional khakis  bindi joined her mom teri and brother  Robert to help feed the crocodiles this  17 year old is seriously fearless just  look at her dangled fat carcass and her  brother Robert is equally impressive  he's literally having a croc standoff  the younger Irwin's sibling celebrated  his 12th birthday on Monday bindi posted  this adorable photo of the duo hugging  writing I can't believe that it was an  entire 12 years ago today when I met my  little brother for the first time since  that day he has grown up to be the  smartest and most amazing boy on earth